à l'école comment le principe de laïcité
est-il perçu comment est-il transmis par
les enseignants et surtout comment
peut-il être partagé par tous telles
étaient les questions auxquelles
entendait répondre ce documentaire
réalisé par Jean crépu un film tourné
vous l'avez vu après l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti et avant celui tout
récemment d'un autre enseignant
Dominique Bernard de nouveau par un
islamiste radical nous allons y revenir
et en débattre maintenant sur ce plateau
de débadoc en compagnie de mes invités
en commençant par vous Alain sexi
bienvenue euh vous êtes un ancien
instituteur inspecteur d'académie
honoraire et membre du conseil des sages
de la laïcité de l'éducation nationale
également avec nous Aicha Béchir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur agrégé de
philosophie vous enseignez à des classes
de terminal cette belle matière qui est
la philosophie votre dernier livre
intitule l'accusation il a été publié
chez Jean-Claude latesse c'est
l'histoire d'ignès he qui est elle aussi
une prof de de philosophie qui a été
accusé d'apologie du terrorisme au au
lendemain des attentats de de Charlie
Hebdo et c'est donc à découvrir chez la
test une assez belle réflexion que vous
livrez là à travers ce cet ouvrage et
puis pierre canne est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes philosophe
historien professeur en sciences de
l'éducation à l'Université de CA et et
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule lui
quelle laïcité voulons-nous donc avec un
point d'interrogation c'est publié chez
ESF éditeur et puis alors dès les
premières phrases de ce livre vous
revendiquez le droit de mettre la
laïcité en question et non pas de la
remettre en question vous nous
expliquerez peut-être ce qu'est votre
vision de cette laïité peut-être à à
rediscuter hein
entre partisans de la laïcité hein il
vous tenait absolument préciser cela
hein ce documentaire que nous venons de
voir a donc été tourné en grande partie
au collège Antonios de Gaulle à Cluse en
Haute Savoie qui compte environ quelques
17000 habitants nous sommes donc dans
une ville moyenne avec beaucoup de
mixité mixité sociale mixité ethnique
tout ça a été très bien expliqué dans
dans ce film et il s'agit là d'un d'un
établissement situé en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire peut-être un
sentiment sur le film que nous venons de
voir la manière dont sont transmises les
valeurs de la République dans cet
établissement par les enseignants
concernés à travers les échanges qu'on a
vu dans ces classes par exemple les les
propos tenus par les enseignants
qu'est-ce que vous retenez pour
l'essentiel de ce de ce film que nous
venons de voir j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce
documentaire je l' trouvé très bien fait
très respectueux de l'école et de des
personnes qui y travaillent des
professeurs des élèves on voit même
d'anciens professeurs euh je l'ai trouvé
très bien fait à juste distance parce
que ça n'est pas simple d'aller tourner
dans dans dans des classes en plus euh
et puis on y entend des des propos
profonds revigorant même je dirais de la
part de professeur et de la part
d'élèves également alors le documentaire
nous dit que certains des propos euh
d'élèves certains propos de certains
élèves
pas été conserv en raison de leur
caractère viol ce qui est une bonne
initiative je crois euh c'est bien de de
de de l'avoir fait ils sont dit cela dit
dans moins ils existent dans les classes
à l'occasion de ces ces cours simplement
pour bien comprendre ce qu'on vient de
voir c'est à l'occasion de la Journée de
la laïcité le 9 décembre donc de chaque
année qu'ont lieu ces ces ces échanges
entre élève sur le
savoir le croire et le savoir hein cette
différence c'est ce qu'on a vu dans ce
film les valeurs de la de la République
c'est à cette occasion là qu'on qu'on a
pu voir ces échanges c'est bien ça oui
c'est tout à fait ça c'est donc c'est
une fois par an c'est une fois par an
c'est-à-dire ça n'empêche pas d'en
parler à d'autres moments même s'il ne
s'agit pas non plus d'en parler en
permanence de ces questions mais entre
ne jamais en parler n'en parler qu'une
fois en parler tout le temps vous
conviendrez qu'il y a de y a de la marge
donc le 9 décembre qui est la date
anniversaire de la promulgation de la
loi du 9 décembre 1905
a longtemps été une date célébrée dans
le seul milieu scolaire c'était la
journée nationale de la laïcité à
l'école
depuis une loi récente la loi de
2021 de confortant les principes de la
République c'est devenu une journée
nationale de la laïcité de manière
générale donc c'est célébré aussi dans
d'autres et chaque enseignant qu'on
comprend bien là aussi peut à tout
moment aborder ces sujets notamment
prenons le l'exemple exemple de la libre
expression à l'occasion de ces cours
pour un prof de littérature de
d'histoire géographie alors non
seulement il peut phosopie non seulement
il peut mais il doit dans certain cas
parce que ça fait ça fait partie des
programmes des programmes nationaux on
doit aborder ces questions et l'histoire
de la laïcité la question de la liberté
d'expression ça fait partie en
particulier des programmes d'éducation
morale et civique bien sûr bon je vous
propose de revoir un un extrait de ce
film c'est justement ce dialogue qui a
été resté à l'occasion de cette fameuse
journée de la laïcité le 9 décembre et
qu'on a déjà vu dans ce documentaire
regardez ce professeur il a été
assassiné un peu injustement parce que
il a fait que faire son cours
et montrer des images qui sont pas
choquantes normalement pour les enfants
je pense que il aurait pas dû montrer
parce que dans notre religion c'est
interdit de montrer un visage d'un
prophète ou quoi que ce soit faut cacher
son visage et du coup je pense qu'il
aurait pas dû le faire il aurait pas dû
montrer une caricature ouis mais alors
là attention parce que on est dans une
école laïque Sirina faut pas oublier ça
c'estàd que la religion à l'école laïque
on la laisse un petit peu de côté tu as
le droit de garder ta religion pour toi
dans voilà respecte pas mais mais
l'école c'est la République française he
l'école c'est l'état elle est
déconnectée de la
religion et on parlait bien sûr de
l'assassinat de de Samuel paatti dans
son établissement de Conflant
saintonorine c'est sont dans les ivelin
en région parisienne euh cet échange par
exemple qu'est-ce qu'il qu'il vous
suggère immédiatement alors il faut
situer déjà cette classe elle a c'est
une classe de qui ont d'élèves qui ont
12 13 ans donc moi je j'arrive en
terminal c'est ils ont fini leur
apprentissage ils sont au bout du cursus
scolaire obligatoire et moi j'ai pas
accès à ce genre d'échange donc ça veut
dire que entre-temps l'école fait son
travail et que il faut partir de ces
préconceptions il faut pas les
dramatiser faut pas les criminaliser il
faut les prendre et les et et travailler
avec parfois ça m'arrive dans mon cours
des élèves qui me disent benant la Bible
dit ça on peut pas dire que comme Sartre
que que Dieu peut ne pas exister ça
c'est un travail que je fais avec eux je
je prends la parole de l'élève telle
qu'elle existe et mon travail c'est pas
de la criminaliser et encore moins de la
signaler selon moi c'est vraiment de
prendre acte de cette parole et et pas
entrer nécessairement dans la
négociation mais de faire en sorte que
cette parole et ben elle trouve sa
place auprès d'une liberté d'opinion
mais qu'elle n'entachche pas le
dispositif du cours et je pense que
toutes ces rappels à l'éducation de la
laïcité en fait c'est ça intervient sur
un cursus qui est assez long et bien
évidemment la licité c'est un cadre
important mais il faut aussi laisser cet
espace de de liberté d'expression des
élèves pour pouvoir les accompagner au
mieux
moi je dirais comme Alain sexi que ce
documentaire est revigorant c'est
exactement le terme que je voulais
employer il m'a paru revigorant parce
que il donne à
voir une vraie communauté éducative de
mon point de vue il donne avoir des
enseignants bienveillants dans un
contexte vous l'avez dit de mixité
sociale et ethnique très important il
donne avoir des élèves de tout origine
qui dansent des danses bretonnes que
j'ai trouvé à la fois sympathique et
amusant et en plus en haut de savoix oui
qui qui qui font du champ il y a
effectivement euh toute une série de
débats alors dans un contexte
particulier qui est celui de la journée
de la naïcité mais enfin visiblement les
élèves
ne ne sont pas euh comment dirais-je
empêché de se sentre autorisé à prendre
la parole il y a là quelque chose qui
m'a appu
euh tout à fait exemplaire de ce que
doit être euh une école laïque et je
suppose j'ai une petite idée là-dessus
euh que ça se passe comme ça dans
énormément d'établissements de collèges
de lycée sans parler de de de l'école
primaire c'est-à-dire euh que la laïcité
bien sûr il y a des choses à enseigner
je suis entièrement entièrement d'accord
il y a des choses à savoir alors adapté
euh à l'âge des enfants à ce qu'ils
peuvent comprendre et cetera et cetera
h
mais la laïcité il faut qu'elle se vive
enfin les valeurs de la République ce
qu'on appelle les valeurs de la
République il faut qu'elle se vive et
vive au au quotidien de ce qu'il se
passe dans une communauté éducative et
et si vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
partage de la licité il me semble ou des
partages des valeurs de la République il
me semble que c'est comme cela que ces
valeurs peuvent être partager au fond la
vraie question c'est puisque ce sont des
valeurs et qu'on veut les transmettre
comme comment faire non pas simplement
pour les dire ou les enseigner mais
comment faire pour qu'ell valent puisque
ce sont des valeurs pour les élèves à
qui on veut les transmettre et il me
semble que ce ce
climat qui existe que le film donne à
voir est tout à fait conforme à à ce
qu'on peut en attendre si je peux juste
dire une petite dernière chose je je
pense à ce que aux analyses récentes de
Gilles kppel sur le le jidaïsme le le j
djihadisme pardon le djihadisme
d'atmosphère et bien je pense que le
meilleur
moyen de lutter contre ce djihadisme
d'atmosphère si s'il existe et je ne
mets pas en cause le fait qu'il est des
analyses de Gilles kpel c'est de
proposer ce que j'appellerais volontiers
une une laïcité d'atmosphère et il me
semble que c'est ce que donne à voir ce
ce film et c'est pour ça que je le
trouve d'un optimisme sympathique et
revigorant alors les atteintes à la
laïcité elles sont comptabilisées
aujourd'hui il y a des signalements avec
un processus d'ailleurs c'est le hein
les enseignants font remonter les
incidents constatés au chef
d'établissement et c'est je crois le
chef d'établissement qui lui-même fait
remonter ça au niveau national vous avez
tout dit c'est exactement de cette
manière là ça de quelle nature sont-ils
pour l'essentiel ces signalements
aujourd'hui alors euh sans remonté à à
plusieurs années où on avait beaucoup de
signalements concernant les tenues euh
manifestant une appartenance religieuse
on a revu ça à comptter disons du mois
de de mars avril 2022 avec le
développement des abayas et des camises
jusqu'à la rentrée dernière où le
ministre a à raison abaya pour les
filles pour les filles pour les garçons
décidé de que c tenue était interdite
mais bien sûr et ça s'est réglé entre de
soit dit en de temps trois mouvements
hein il y a eu euh encore quelques
élèves qui se sont présentés aveces s
tenu pendant une semaine 8 jours 10
jours et puis on en parle plus
aujourd'hui il il n'y en a plus hein
alors ces signalements remontent
effectivement auprès d'une cellule
appropriée qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon équipe académique valeur de la
République c'est même en abrégé e av VR
personne peut comprendre donc c'est une
équipe placée auprès des recteurs
d'académie qui sont composé d'inspecteur
d'académie de de chefs d'établissement
de professeurs et qui viennent en appui
des établissements d'ailleurs très
concrètement ces équipes étaient dès le
jour de la rentrée auprès des
enseignants et des équipes de direction
dans les établissements pour aider
justement à la mise en œuvre de ce
qu'avait décidé le ministre à travers
une note de service c'estàdire
l'interdiction de C tenue c'est
signalement auutau de Moné après la
merre de semelpatti tous les chiffres le
disent au total on a noté 4710 atteintes
à la laïicité pour l'année scolaire
2022- 2023 ils étaient 2000 167 l'année
précédente c'est donc plus du double en
Adant essentiellement c'est c'est
signalement concerernit donc les tenues
vestimentaires les abayas les cam que
vous avez évoquéc oui ça peut concerner
d'autres moments de de la vie scolaire
des des des moments où où le principe de
laïcité est contesté déjà dans les cours
dans les contenus même
d'enseignement voilà on peut avoir àaire
à des contestations de contenu de cours
alors contestation après tout un élève
peut dire je suis pas d'accord avec ça
j'ai pas bien compris ça ça fait partie
du quotidien de la classe vous
professeur qui allez dire le contraire
surtout en philosophie on discute bon
mais il y a des contestations qui se
font plus violentes ou alors des
manifestations qui peuvent être
silencieuses mais qui sont une violence
faite au professeurs et et et au corps
professoral de manière générale et au
contenu d'enseignement c'est par exemple
quand on se bouche les oreilles ou qu'on
se ferme les yeux pour ne pas
entendre ou voir le document que propose
le professeur c'est vrai par exemple on
a eu plusieurs signalements on veut
présenter Nuit et Brouillard à une
classe et puis des élèves se bouchent
les oreilles et se ferment les yeux par
exemple est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on ne réagit pas on dit après tout
c'est son droit de de de ne pas regarder
ben non il y a
euh le professeur doit agir parce que ce
sont des connaissances des faits de
connaissance qui doivent être porté
donné à tous ce que j'ai apprécié par ex
dans les dialogues entre élèves
également l'un d'eux dit à un moment
donné on ne doit pas chercher à
influencer les autres à croire ou à ne
pas croire c'est le débat sur on peut
croire ou ne pas croire et la professeur
d'ailleurs a
raison revient là-dessus en parlant des
croyances et des connaissances c'est ce
que tu crois ou ce que tu sais par
exemple dit-elle et c'est tout à fait
précieux d'amener des élèves à faire la
distinction entre ce qui est de l'ordre
des croyances et ce qui est de l'ordre
de la connaissance scientifique qui doit
être porté par l'école alors concernant
ces ces remontées qui concernent pour
beaucoup hein là les tenues
vestimentaires et c'est interdiction la
BAA du camis annoncé par le le le
ministre de l'éducation nationale lors
de cette rentrée vous avez vous cette
cette réaction si on voulait politiser
les jeunes fille qui porte la BAA on ne
pourrait pas mieux le faire ça donne à
la BAA le sens d'un engagement politique
cela donne à ces jeunes F une cause à
défendre euh c'est ce qui s'est passé en
2004 avec le voile dites-vous donc vous
n'étiez pas forcément partisane d'une
intervention comme celle qu'a pris le
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
était l'interdiction purure et simple ce
que j'aimerais juste souligner c'est
qu'en premier lieu la la Baya c'était
pas un fait aussi courant que l'on
présentait c'était quelques dizaines de
cas et c'est sans doute aussi pour cette
raison que ça s'est réglé aussi vite
c'est que il y a pas eu de protestation
de ces jeunes filles effectivement pour
moi ça aurait pu politiser ces jeunes
filles en se donnant une cause à
défendre et ça pouvait être aussi
dangereux pour cette raison
euh forcé de constater que ça n'a pas
été le cas parce que aussi on surestime
et peut-être moi la première leur
implication politique et c'est aussi
cela que je dénonçais en en en suggérant
que cette abaya était finalement le
vecteur d'un islamisme ou d'un
anentrisme religieux c'est aussi ça que
que je que je voulais souligner en ce
qui concerne la habaya il faut aussi se
dire que ce sont des jeunes filles que
parfois elle ne conscientisse pas
réellement pourquoi elle le porte que
moi j'ai constaté que par exemple à la
fin d'année quand il y a beaucoup
d'examens scolair ben elles avaient
tendance à le porter parce qu'elles
étaient tout simplement fatiguées et que
elles ne voulaient pas porter autre
chose mais il fallait pas y voir une une
intention religieuse ou une intention
politique vous dites le débat actuel sur
la laïcité ne pose pas un camp laïque à
un camp antilïque comme c'était le cas
il y a 150 ans au moment de la naissance
de l'école républicaine le débat oppose
artisan partisan et partisan et vous
dites que ce débat finalement qu'on a eu
il y a peu de temps he sur la BAA on a
eu le même débat en quelque sorte en
2004 à momentomo de de de la loi
interdisant les les signes ostentatoir
les signes religieux ostentatoires à
l'école je crois que c'est c'est c'est
simple il y a il me semble enfin que
aujourd'hui la laïcité est l'objet de ce
que j'appelle un conflit des
interprétations c'està-dire que vous
avez des approches qui sont sensiblement
différentes avec d'ailleurs des tas de
nuances et d'intermédiaires entre ces
approches hein c'est pas une opposition
absolu et frontal entre deux camps mais
des approches
différentestis entre partisans
c'est-à-dire je suis pas sûr que j'ai
exactement la même position sur la
laïcité qu' qu'alin sexig euh je pense
que il y a un certain nombre de choses
notamment par exemple dans la loit de
2004 qui me pose
problème dans la loi de 2011 sur le
séparatime qui me pose problème qui pose
problème à un certain nombre d'autres
personnes ce qui ne veut pas dire que je
ne suis pas du tout un partisan alors
qu'est-ce qui vous posez problème sur le
port des signes religieux tentatoires à
l'école cette fameuse loi 2004 pour êt
très concret al très concret je vais
essayer d'être le plus concret possible
et le plus simple possible ce ce qui me
pose problème c'est pas l'interdiction
en elle-même j'étais je je comprenais
parfaitement moi j'ai suivi ces affaires
depuis très longtemps hein depuis
89 je voyais bien ce qui se passait dans
les salles de classe les les tensions
extraordinaires que ça pouvait susciter
entre les professeurs entre les élèves
ça empêché littéralement certains
établissements de fonctionner donc d'une
certaine façon
l'interdiction me paraissait de ce point
de vue justifié euh ce qui m'a beaucoup
gêné paradoxalement c'est qu'elle se
fasse en application du principe de
laïcité moi j'y voyais beaucoup plus et
je pense qu'elle aurait bien gagné être
justifié non pas en fonction de
l'application du principe de laïcité
mais en fonction de ce qui le limite
c'est-à-dire des nécessités d'ordre
public il y avait là une confusion me
semble-t-il entre laïcité et ordre
public c'estàdire très exactement si on
prend la lettre de la l'article 1 de la
loi 1905 entre la laïit
et ses limites qui me paraissaient tout
à fait préjudiciable et ça a eu un effet
à mon avis relativement désastreux à
terme auprès des élèves c'est que ça
induit l'idée que la laïcité c'est avant
tout un ensemble d'interdiction alors
qu'il me semble que la laïcité c'est
d'abord un principe de liberté alors je
vous laisse répondre cette fois c'est
d'abord un principe de liberté et
pierentendre dire après lui que nous
pouvons être parfaitement d'accord sur
beaucoup de points qu'il a euh dit là
qu'il a énuméré à l'instant à commencé
par le fait que dès 89 on a bien vu que
la laïcité n'opposait pas partisan et
adversaires de la laïcité mais qu'on a
assisté à ce moment-là à un débat
interne au partisans de la laïcité c'est
tout à tout à fait juste bon il il me
semble que avec une laïité qu'on
pourrait peut-être qualifier libérale
libérale me convient très bien une une
laïité plus stricte hein pour peut-être
schématiser un peu on se dispenserait
des adjectifs que ce serait mieux moi je
suis partisan de la laïcité je suis
laïque ou comme dirait Robert baninter
lacar mais ça ne me gêne pas hein de de
qu'on dis cela moi il me semble que nous
devions faire face en 89
à une montée en
puissance particulière ça n'était pas
quelques dizaines d'élèves qui étaient
concernés par le voile ça a été très
rapidement 5000 6000 7000 élèves qui
était concerné il est évident qu'en 89
on avait tous les moyens pour régler ça
sans recours à la loi il lui suffit de
dire non à ces signes voilà au nom des
des principes qui régissent le
fonctionnement de l'école publique et
Laï ça aurait été très simple on n' pas
su le faire il y a eu des atermoiements
et au plus haut niveau de l'État qui se
sont traduit très concrètement pendant
15 ans pendant 15 ans par une
application à géométrie variable du même
principe républicain de laïcité par les
mêmes fonctionnaires d'État que sont les
enseignants les chefs d'établissement et
cetera de manière très différente dans
un établissement un chef d'établissement
pour pouvait dire ça ne me dérange pas
les élèves peuvent venir en harborant
des signes étenus manifestant une
appartenance religieuse et dans un dans
un autre quelquefois voisin de quelques
centaines de mètres c'était la position
inverse qui était adoptée donc nous
avons connu et dans les deux cas ça
produisait par définition du conflit de
la discorde bon donc on a perdu cette
cohérence cette cohérence qui existait
avant parce
que avant 89 on n'en parlait pas de
laïcité à l'école moi quand j'ai
commencé comme instituteur on parlait
jamais on en parlait même plus dans le
cadre de la formation d'une certaine
manière c'est ce qu'on a payé mais on on
pensait que la question était réglé
depuis longtemps si vous voulezelle est
apparu avec force là vous souhaitez
réagir oui je je je partage l'idée
qu'effectivement il faut homogénéiser
nos pratiques c'est l'école publique et
républicaine mais ce qu'il faut aussi
souligner c'est qu'à partir de 2004 on
on on considère que la laïcité
s'applique aussi aux élèves et c'est ça
une c'est aussi une exception à partir
de 2900 la loi 1905 pardon et c'est
justement ça qui a aussi créé du débat
dans la communauté éducative alors je je
peux répondre directement rapidement et
puis ensuite je vous donne la
parole je citais tout à l'heure cet
élève qui
dit il faut veiller on doit pas chercher
à influencer les autres à croire ne pas
croire c'est exactement ce que dit
l'article 31 de la loi de 1905 qui punit
de peine d'emprisonnement et de et
d'amende aujourd'hui c'est 15000 € je
crois ceux qui font pression qui pourrai
faire pression et et faire pr de menace
contre un individu en vue de le
déterminer à exercer ou à s'abstenir
d'exercer un culte c'est en cela c'est
en cela que la loi du 15 mars 2004 est
en parfaite continuité avec la loi de
1905 et il y a pas que moi qui le dis
c'est tous ceux qui siégeaient les les
les 20 membres peut-être à l'exception
de l'un deux qui si à la commission
St encore faut-il considérer les les
certains signes religieux comme du
prosélitisme ça c'est une enfin c'est
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut discuter
d'autant plus que vous semblez suggérer
que dans c c Abila vous vous vous prêtez
une certaine menace ce qui est pas
nécessairement simplement je m'adresse
là au
professeurilos de l'éducation
l'assassinat a de de deux enseignants
c'est c'est un fait unique dans
l'histoire
euh de l'école de la République
absolument ah bah évidemment c'est c'est
un fait unique c'est un fait
particulièrement bouleversant ouais
évidemment donc c'est dansun contexte
unique historique jamais vu que les
enseignants qu'on a vu dans ce
documentaire transmettent ses valeurs au
sein de l'école est-ce que vous
comprenez par exemple parfois qu'il a
une forme d'hésitation à à entrer sur ce
terrain pour les enseignants on l'a bien
vu hein dans dans dans ce film
euh d'une autocensure j'ai entendu
souvent ce ce terme arrivver dans dans
la bouche des enseignants aujourd'hui on
s'autocensure dans dans nos
établissements scolaires sur ces
questions pour la plupart des
enseignants alors honnêtement
euh je je n'en sais rien je j'ai pas
d'enquête à ma disposition qui
permettrait de dire si on suto censure
et j'ai en plus pas d'élément qui me
permettent de comprendre prendre ce que
signifie le fait de s'autocensurer qui
peut signifier plusieurs choses qui peut
signifier par exemple oh ça je veux pas
en parler je m'interdis de le faire
parce que parce que j'ai peur tout
simplement qu'il m'arrive quelque choseô
comme çaentend dans le contexte
peut-être ça n'est pas uniquement l' le
sens de l'attitude des enseignants qui
n'en parlent pas ça peut être aussi par
exemple l'expression d'un
scrupule je sais pas si je dois parler
de telle chose ou comm je dois parler de
quelque chose moi j'étais enseignant
dans le le secondaire pendant pendant 15
ans c'est une question que je me posais
à peu près constamment ou hein c'est une
question déontologique d'une certaine
façon alors si on m'avait interrogé
est-ce que vous
autocensurez j'aurais essayé de dire non
ça j'appelle pas ça l'autocensure mais
si c'est rangé dans l'autocensure oui
que ça ça ça ça c'est un ensemble
extrêmement ééroclite objectivement la
CAPAC enfin comment on pourrait mesurer
cette autocensure et en quoi finalement
elle porte préjudice à notre
enseignement c'est de savoir si les si
les professeurs font ou non leur
programme et il me semble que jamais un
professeur ne se dit je ne vais pas
aborder cette question du programme pour
pour éviter de d'avoir des problèmes par
exemple on fait croire que les
enseignants d'histoire géo ne feraient
pas la mémoire de la chois ce qui n'est
pas vrai Yanis Rodi a répondu récemment
pour dire que c'était pas possible de ne
pas faire le programme et que parfois
effectivement il y a des il y a des
discussions autour de cette question il
y a des douleurs aussi on peut pas dire
à un élève de 14 ans le drame qui a été
la chois sans avoir une une enfin une
des difficulté personnelle à affronter
les questions de de jeunes adolescents
mais à aucun moment on ne tergivers sur
le programme scolaire et ça c'est très
important parce que c'est la garantie de
not de notre école est
républicaine c'est Yanis roder donc
par ce fameux
comm comité également
heinve conse autensure est-ce qu'on a un
moyen de le l'estimer aujourd'hui du
côté de l'éducation nationale je je vais
venir je parle de Yanis RER parce qu'il
se trouve que par ailleurs il est un un
des membres actifs de la Fondation Jean
jorè et qu'à ce titre il a dirigé une
étude qui date de de quelques années qui
est une des premières avec l'Ifop Ifop
fondation gegeorest une des premières
études à avoir signalé ce phénomène
d'autocensure des professeurs hein euh
qui qui est un phénomène corroboré par
une autre étude qui a été menée l'n
l'année dernière par le principal
syndicat de chef d'établissement le
Syndicat national des personnels de
direction de l'éducation nationale en
abrégé SNPDEN et qui montre mais c'est
courageux de leur part parce que ils
interrogent beaucoup de leurs confrères
chefs d'établissement qui disent à
raison de allez disons 2 sur C qu'ils ne
font pas remonté un certain nombre
d'informations qui sont trop sensibles
alors il peut y avoir des tas de raisons
la crainte d'être considéré comme un
chef d'établissement qui ne tient pas
bien sa boutique si vous voulez des
choses comme ça mais n'empêche que le
phénomène est là il faut bien s'y
pencher mais si ça vous ennuie pas je
voudrais revenir sur quelque chose sur
le débat précédent j'is bien vous en
restiez sur l'autocensure parce que ça
semble quand même un problème
central ce que j'ai j'ai lu vous citez
une étudiphobe d'ailleurs je l'ai sous
les yeux oui oui si vousedonnez la
parole sur le point que je veux que je
voulais aborder tout à l'heure je
m'arrête là mais je voudrais répondre
quand même concernant les abaillards
alors les abaillard rapidement he parce
que très rapidement très rapidement on
peut s'imaginer que c'est de l'ordre de
la fantaisie adolescente mais bien naïf
celui qui croit ça j'en veux pour preuve
ce qui s'est passé la toute première
fois qu'on a eu des abaillats dans un
établissement scolaire vous le savez
c'est en
2011 c'était dans un L de scène
Saint-Denis à sainttoouin et qui était
derrière qui venait appuyer les jeunes
filles qui portaient les abaillard on
retrouvver une association le collectif
cher Yassin présidé par abdelakim
sefriou qui a joué le rôle funestre que
chacun sait dans l'assassinat de Samuel
pati qui est aujourd'hui en prison donc
je veux bien que ce soit de l'ORD de la
fantaisie adolescente mais voilà les
forces qui soutiennent la BAA donc il
suffirrait juste d'enlever la BAA pour
se pour se séparer du du terrorisme mais
c'est important de le faire je dis ça
règle tout magiquement aucune mesure ne
règlera magiquement tous les problèmes
le diadisme c'est vit encore hein enfin
on le sait c'est un combat de longue
haleine oui c'est pas une question de
alors j'ai vu dans ce je sais pas si
c'estur voulu juste avant ré non je je
voulais dire pour revenir sur sur
l'autocensure ou ce que je voulais dire
tout à l'heure c'est qu'il faut se
méfier de la façon dont on catégorise un
certain nombre de comportements et qu'on
met peut-être ensemble hein des
comportements d'enseignants qui n'ont
pas le même sens et que le fait déjà de
se poser la question en terme
d'autocensure n'est pas complètement
neutre hein de même la l'enquête de la
Fondation jean-
jorè dirigé si je puis dire par par
Yanis roder elle est pas non plus d'une
certain façon complètement neutre alors
je ne la remets pas en cause pas du tout
mais ce que je sais je je le dis dans
mon livre d'ailleurs c'est que au même
moment en 2000 20 donc un an avant cette
enquête il y a une autre enquête de la
part du knesco qui n'existe plus à ma
connaissance le Conseil national de
l'évaluation scolaire qui aboutit à des
résultats à peu près systématiquement
inverses alors je ne sais pas est-ce que
ça veut dire que le knesco a raison et
que le la Fondation je évidemment je ne
diraiis pas ça mais c'est de nature à
prendre les choses avec un certain
nombre de circonspection qu'est-ce que
dans dans une enquête quel type de
question qu'on pose comment on induit
éventuellement même innocemment si je
puis dire entre guillemets euh ce les
réponses tout ça est quand même
compliqué il y a ça ça contribue alors
surtout l'enquête de euh de la fondation
jeanerè qui montre également que euh un
certain nom qui dit en tout cas qu'un
certain nombre d'enseignants je crois de
mémoire que c'est 25 % euh auraiit été
plutôt en désaccord avec ce qu'avait
fait euh Samuel paatti dans son cours et
ça ça ça accrédite l'idée que il y a une
espèce de de terreur totale qui règne
sur le monde enseignant qui qui
entretient un climat de ce que j'appelle
dans mon livre une panique morale et qui
ne me semble pas de nature à faire
avancer de façon très constructive le
problème lorsqu'on rapporte des des des
des entors justement à à la laïcité du
côté des des élèves quelles sont les
sanctions encourues est-ce que cela peut
permettre davantage de sénérité du côté
des du corps enseignant alors avant
toute sanction il y a une phase de
dialogue et qui est rappelé et encouragé
dans nos textes et pas d'aujourd'hui
depuis la loi de 2004 la circulaire
d'application de la loi de 2004 le
prévoyait déjà donc une phase de
dialogue qui est souvent suffisante pas
toujours évidemment mais souvent
suffisante une phase de dialogue qui
n'est pas pour reprendre votre terme de
tout à l'heure qui n'est pas de l'ordre
de la négociation qui est un moment où
on expose justement les principes
républicains qui doivent régir l'école
ça veut dire tous ceux qui participe à
l'école tout le monde et tous les élèves
hein ça s'applique aux élèves comme ça
s'applique bien entendu aux professeurs
donc après cette phase de dialogue si on
voit que les choses sont impossibles il
y a un conseil de discipline qui est
convoqué dans l'établissement ou hors
l'établissement quelquefois ça peut se
trouver et là des sanctions peuvent être
prises qui vont d'un renvoi euh comment
dire de l'établissement non
temporaireire c'est le terme un renvoi
définitif de de de de l'établissement ça
peut arriver bien entendu et c'est le
dialogue qui est tout de même privilégié
vous l'avez dit on l'a vu dans ce
documentaire en tout cas pour les
enseignants qui officiai àuses à
l'occasion de ce ce film grand merci à
tous les trois c'est déjà la fin de ce
débat aujourd'hui sur la transmission
des de la des valeurs de la laïcité au
sein de nos établissements scolaires vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtagdbat dog
merci à Selma S qui comme elle accoutumé
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission
prochain rendez-vous avec desbadog ça
sera bien sûr avec son documentaire et
son débat à très
bientôt
[Musique]